lieber rieso du bist heute
wissenschaftlich geprüft freunde der
sonne lässt keine zeit verlieren alle
aber wirklich alle reden über jesus
video war es ihr das video noch nicht
gesehen habt dann zieht euch diese ja
knappe stunde durchaus mal rein
ich interessiere mich heute ganz
besonders für einen teil nämlich von
minute sechs ungefähr bis minute 15
einhalb denn hier haut wieso fakten über
den kindern raus und ich finde es
deswegen so wichtig weil erstens es gibt
derzeit kein dringender das ist
politisches thema als den klimawandel
und zweitens dürfen hier gleichzeitig
keine politischen meinungen zählen
sondern nur seien jetzt sagen ganz viele
was heißt schon dieser blaue haarige
musik youtuber über science sei solches
jetzt deutlich mehr als viele politiker
aber eins nach dem andern ich habe in
diesen zehn minuten von jesus video 12
aussagen zum klimawandel festgemacht und
wenn ihr wissenschaftlich geprüft kennt
dann wisst ihr was jetzt kommt ich werde
diese zwölf aussagen nacheinander
durchgehend ich werde wissenschaftlich
approvals verteilen und ich werde am
ende natürlich auch ein
wissenschaftliches gesamturteil geben
für diesen klima teil von wieso also man
es euch gemüt nicht setzt euch los
geht's fangen wir mit den basics an zwei
aussagen von wieso die wir schnell
abhaken können erstens die letzten vier
jahre waren die wärmsten jahre seit
beginn der aufzeichnungen
es wird warm 2018 war das führt wärmste
jahr seit beginn der
wetteraufzeichnungen also jetzt sagte
vielleicht ja mensch das führt wärmste
jahr das sind ja noch drei jahre wärmer
wisst ihr welche 2015 16 und 17 2 die
globale durchschnittstemperatur ist um
etwa ein grad gestiegen im vergleich zur
vorindustriellen zeit und das alles ist
bereits passiert weil es ein grad
durchschnittlich wärmer geworden ist
damit direkt zwei profis zum anfang
temperaturdaten kann jeder nachschauen
wieso hat es verlinkt ich habe auch noch
mal was in der video beschreibung
verlinkt und temperaturdaten da gibt es
halt auch nicht so viel
interpretationsspielraum interessanter
wird es bei den punkten gründe für den
klimawandel und folgen des klimawandels
fangen wir an mit den folgen es gibt ja
menschen die sagen es gäbe gar keine
nennenswerten folgen
wann ist sondern das wäre vor allem nur
panikmache das greift wieso auf hiermit
ein grad ist verdammt viel wer sich
jetzt denkt so 12 grad machen die denn
so einen großen unterschied den kann ich
sagen ja machen sie oder auch in anderen
worten viele denken ein grad 23 grad was
macht den unterschied
als arzt kann ich ihnen sagen es macht
einen großen unterschied ob sie 41 grad
fieber haben oder 43
das eine ist mit dem leben vereinbar das
andere nicht also dieses zitat von
eckart von hirschhausen alleine ist
jetzt noch nicht wirklich überzeugend
war das ist jetzt erst mal nur eine
analogie und keine begründung also der
körper und der planet es sind zwei
verschiedene systeme aber eckart von
hirschhausen hat als arzt und
wissenschaftsjournalist sicherlich noch
mehr zusagen zu klimawandel und
gesundheit deswegen habe ich ihn
kurzerhand gebieten einfach mal
persönlich vorbeizukommen um es
loszuwerden achtung er hatte so ein
geplatztes äderchen im auge das sah sehr
scary aus aber keine sorge alles gut
nicht irritieren lässt
wir kennen die mit einer roten nase im
gesicht heute mit dem roten augen
platzen geht von alleine weg aber welche
mal klimawandel gesundheit wer platz bin
ich noch nichts mehr klagt unser körper
ist ein kraftwerk wir erzeugen ständig
in uns mehr wärme als wir brauchen für
die körpertemperatur und das geht alles
gut solange es draußen kühler ist also
in unser hirn kann unter direkter
sonneneinstrahlung einen hitzschlag oder
einen sonnenstich bekommen und menschen
unter fieber kriegen ja auch wann
zustände das heißt unser hirn ist extrem
thermo labil und auf wunsch wird drehen
durch und kippen rum wenn es zu heiß
wird hitze tote gibt es in europa und
unser gesundheitswesen ist sowas von gar
nicht darauf vorbereitet mit dem ansturm
von leuten die plötzlich kollabieren
umzugehen
es gibt keine pille gegen eine hohe
außentemperaturen deswegen müssen wir
jetzt handeln damit die erde ein
bisschen chillig bleiben kann wenn man
gesundheit mal ein bisschen weiter denkt
dann brauchen wir menschen dringend eine
gesunde erde um uns herum
dh moderner tui hält unsere eigene
körperliche gesundheit hängt davon ab
dass die ökosysteme um uns herum
funktionieren wir brauchen wasser zum
trinken wir brauchen nahrungsmittel und
wir brauchen auch luft zum atmen klingt
so einfach ist es aber nicht das alles
still wir nicht industriell her
das sind alles millionenwerte die
natur und zur verfügung stellt so haben
wir die natur nicht zerstören damit wäre
auch jesus vierte aussage prüft nämlich
klimawandel schadet unserer gesund es
wird dann nämlich mehr krankheiten für
uns geben also näher als je mehr
infektionskrankheiten und allergien
beispiel in süddeutschland ist es
inzwischen warm genug für die asiatische
tigermücke so erhöht sich die gefahr für
tropische infektionskrankheiten in
gebieten die früher noch zu kalt war
eckert hat übrigens auch noch mehr zu
sagen dazu kommen wir auch gleich doch
vorher noch weitere folgen des
klimawandels aussage fünf klimawandel
führt zu mehr naturkatastrophen
naturkatastrophen nehmen durch die
erderwärmung zu deren folgen und das
ausmaß nimmt zu und die unmittelbaren
kosten sind jetzt schon jährlich
hunderte milliarden das extremwetter
ereignisse wie dürren feuer hochwasser
starkregen stürmer usw uns nicht nur
leben sondern auch geld kosten dürfte
klar sein aber ist denn wirklich der
klimawandel daran schuld kurz gesagt ja
aber nicht alleine denn prinzipiell kann
man ein einzelnes wetterereignis niemals
nur den klimawandel zu schreiben denn
welche ereignisse sind sehr komplex sie
hängen von vielen verschiedenen faktoren
ab weswegen wir ja auch das wetter nur
bedingt voraussagen können voraussagen
ist aber auch immer was anderes als
rückblickend analysieren da ist die
wissenschaft inzwischen ganz gut es gibt
inzwischen immer mehr sogenannte
attributen studies die uns verraten wie
groß der einfluss also wie groß die
schuld des klimawandels an einzelnen
naturkatastrophen war und kann
inzwischen nämlich ganz gut simulieren
was passiert wäre gäbe es keinen
menschengemachten klimawandels auch wenn
manche naturkatastrophen auch ohne
menschengemachten klimawandel passiert
wären dann doch nicht so heftig oder in
einem derart großen ausmaßes heißt der
klimawandel macht naturkatastrophen
schlimmer ganz allgemein gesagt auch
wenn man jedes einzelne individuelle
event auch individuell analysieren muss
was passiert noch wenn es wärmer wird in
deutschland jetzt erstmal nur reise
allein das macht schon einige menschen
zu schaffen wie eckart vorn erklärt hat
aber es gibt tatsächlich auch gegenden
auf dieser welt wo die erderwärmung zu
einer verbesserung führen
kann zum beispiel gibt es dann
fruchtbare böden in sibirien
das wissen die wissenschaftler auch also
auch das ip-tv das intergovernmental
panel on climate change in deutschland
eher bekannt als der weltklimarat auch
die haben das in ihren berechnungen
schon mit einbezogen und kommen aber
zweifelsfrei zu dem schluss die größe
die erderwärmung desto größer auch die
netto schäden für diesen ganz planeten
es ein pc oder weltklimarat ist übrigens
ein internationaler zusammenschluss von
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern also geballte
verlässliche kompetenz und in sachen
klima definitiv die experten auf die wir
und die politik hören sollten also
global betrachtet führt der klimawandel
zu wasserknappheit schlechteren er
hunger konflikten krieg um ressourcen
und dazu dass immer mehr menschen ihre
heimat verlassen müssen diese generellen
zusammenhänge sind unumstritten aber wie
groß ist das ausmaß aussage sechs
klimawandel führt zu mehr migration die
internationale organisation für
migration hat vor ein paar jahren
berechnet das so in 30 jahren etwa 230
millionen leute in anderen ländern
unterkommen müssen da wir uns aber dann
in der zwischenzeit auch nicht so einem
guten kurs befunden haben geht sie jetzt
mittlerweile schon von über 400
millionen flüchtlingen aus nur so als
größenordnung in der eu sind so gut 500
millionen resultierte wie gesagt den
world migration report wobei man auch
aufpassen muss im report steht auch dass
man diese zahlen nicht akkurat
voraussagen kann
trotzdem diese größenordnung von
hunderten millionen
damit müssen wir durchaus rechnen die am
meisten zitierte schätzung beläuft sich
auf 200 millionen migranten bis 2050 auf
das pc also der weltklimarat zitierte
diese zahl also auch hier ruft außer
gesehen klimawandel führt zu
massenaussterben außerdem sterben 100
mal schneller tierarten aus als vorher
verlieren komplette lebensräume die
korallenriffe und biologen sagen sogar
dass ein neues massenaussterben
wahrscheinlich passieren wird so
verweist auf diese viel zitierte studie
die von einem sechsten massenaussterben
spricht kritiker sagen artensterben wir
auch auf natürliche art und weise aus
also im laufe der evolution aber wer
hier richtig zitiert hier handelt es
sich um eine 100 fach höhere
aussterberate als zuvor
dieses ausmaßes eben nicht folge der
evolution sondern im gegenteil die
evolution kommt ich mir mit mit den
drastischen veränderungen auf diesem
planeten deswegen auch hier leider
geprüft sowie zu den folgen kommen wir
jetzt zu den gründen für den klimawandel
auch hier erst mal die basics außerdem
acht die erderwärmung wird durch
treibhausgase wie co2 und methan
verursacht erster linie passiert das
durch die gase co2 und methan
je mehr davon in der luft ist desto
wärmer bezahlt reden wir nur von co2 das
liegt daran dass wir treibhausgase wie
methan oft in co2 äquivalente umrechnen
das heißt co2 ist nicht nur das
häufigste treibhausgas sondern auch das
referenz treibhausgas eigentlich ist co2
er ganz natürlich wäre so auch in seinem
video erklärt ich kann mich da nur
anschließen in der luft fliegt
kohlenstoff in form von co2 jahre
pflanzen können das co2 aus der luft in
komplexere kohlenstoffhaltige moleküle
umwandeln zucker- stärke- fette wir
essen diese kohlenstoffhaltigen
verbindungen und wandeln sie um und sie
atmen co2 wieder aus das können die
pflanzen dann wieder aufnehmen unsere
schließt sich der kohlenstoffkreislauf
jetzt ist co2 aber auch ein treibhausgas
und das problem ist dass wir das schon
lange nicht mehr nur ausatmen sondern
durch industrie und co sehr viel mehr
davon frei setzen nur haben wir nicht
entsprechend mehr pflanzen und das führt
zu einer erwärmung des klimas
allerdings sagt wieso auch deswegen
blieb
die menge von co2 über millionen von
jahre ziemlich gleich und das ist in
dieser verkürzung nicht ganz richtig und
zwar lasst uns das etwas genauer
anschauen die luft die jetzt vor
tausenden von jahren hier auf dem
planeten war die ist archiviert und zwar
im ewigen eis zb in der antarktis dort
können wir in die eisschichten
reinschauen die tiefer desto älter ist
die luft die wir dort eingeschlossen
finden und können dann die genaue
zusammensetzung bestimmen mit den
dicksten eisschichten können der 800.000
jahre in die vergangenheit blicken und
den co2 gehalt ziemlich akkurat
bestimmen und hier sehen wir dass sich
der co2 gehalt im laufe der
erdgeschichte durchaus ändert und zwar
liegt das an sachen wie das die erde um
die sonne er so in der mit der
umlaufbahn waber zwischen er rund und er
oval und dadurch kriegt die erde mal
mehr mal weniger sonne ab so und durch
noch andere faktoren entstehen dann
sachen wie eiszeiten oder kaltzeit
müsste man genauer sagen und warmzeiten
durch diesen blick in die vergangenheit
wissen wir dass co2 mit klimaerwärmung
zusammenhängt ja das liegt unter anderem
daran dass co2 in dem wärmeren mehr
schlechter lustig ist es kommt mehr an
die atmosphäre und dadurch erwärmt sich
die erde zusätzlich weil co2 eben ein
treibhausgas ist und das ist jetzt genau
der punkt wo klimawandel leugner drauf
aufspringen und sagen seht ihr dass dort
völlig normal das gab es in der
vergangenheit schon diese waren zeiten
warum sollte uns das jetzt jürgen weil
der anstieg von co2 den wir heute
verursachen
fast 100 mal schneller ist als das hier
wir haben jetzt schon einen höheren wert
erreicht als jemals für die vergangene
nacht hunderttausend jahre gemessen
wurde und überhaupt ist das große
argument das gab es früher schon ist
ganz natürlich völlig nichtssagend
stelle ich mal vorstand der erderwärmung
wird jetzt eine eiszeit bevorstehen ja
da wird doch auch keiner kommen und
sagen also eiszeiten gab es schon immer
nach dem presse jedenfalls im gegensatz
zu natürlichen klimaveränderungen wie es
sie in der geschichte der erde schon
gegeben hat ist der springende punkt
jetzt dass beim aktuellen klimawandel
mir etwas dagegen tun können denn außer
genau
der mensch ist am klimawandel schuld und
wer ist daran schuld wir zu 100
der anstieg von kohlendioxid in der
atmosphäre der inzwischen 45 prozent
beträgt der ist zu 100 vom menschen
verursacht das ist vollkommen
unumstritten in der wissenschaft und
diese aussage ist mit einer sehr
wichtigen zweiten aussage verknüpft
nämlich über den menschengemachten
klimawandel besteht wissenschaftliche
konsens ich habe diese frage einfach mal
klimaforschung gestellt also ich habe
diese institute angerufen und gesagt ich
mir so es gibt keinen einzigen seriösen
wissenschaftler der das gegenteil
behauptet eine zahl die immer wieder
fällt ist 97 prozent 97 prozent der
klimaforscher seien sich einig aber
immer wieder hört man 7 90 prozent
intake das wurde schon längst die bahn
mit dieser studie ist unwissenschaftlich
schauen wir uns diese vermag nicht um
wissenschaftliche studien doch mal
genauer an wir befinden uns jetzt an
einem ganz wichtigen knackpunkt dieser
debatte
deswegen brauche ich eure volle
aufmerksamkeit in dieser studie die
herausfinden wollte wie einig sich die
wissenschaft ist hat man sich 12.000
studien über den klimawandel genommen
und von jeder studie den abstract
durchgelesen der abstract einer studie
ist eine zusammenfassung wo die
wichtigsten methoden und ergebnisse drin
stehen diese abstracts kann man jetzt
aufteilen in neutral neutral bedeutet
dass in diesen abstracts die ursachen
des klimawandels nicht erwähnt wurden
also nicht thematisiert wurden und zu
schreiben und das heißt in diesen apps 6
wurde die ursache des klimawandels
erwähnt oder thematisiert 66 prozent
dieser abstracts waren neutral
das heißt wie gesagt nicht dass die sich
unterhalten haben oder so sondern die
ursache des klimawandels wurde in diesen
elf tracks in diesen zusammenfassungen
nicht erwähnt in den anderen apps tracks
in denen die ursachen erwähnt wurden
waren es zu 97,1 menschen gemacht also
97,1 prozent sagen der mensch ist schuld
am klimawandel sieht nicht alle
klimaforscher oder alle klima schulen
beschäftigen sich mit den ursachen des
klimawandels was auch logisch dass ich
beim klimaforschung ist ein sehr breites
komplexes forschungsgebiet deshalb gibt
es bei solchen konsens studien immer
wissenschaftler die neutral sind was
nichts anderes heißt als diese
wissenschaftler haben sich in ihrer
wissenschaftlichen arbeit nicht mit der
ursache mensch beschäftigt und genau
diese neutralität die wird von
klimawandel skeptikern oft
missverstanden weil sie dann sagen jedes
stimmt doch gar nicht mit dem konsens
denn großer teil hat sich ja enthalten
aber nein das ist keine inhalte hier
geht es nicht um meinung das ist hier
keine demokratische abstimmung
deswegen ist es auch nur sinnvoll nur
diejenigen experten zu befragen die auch
wirklich experten sind und die sich
damit beschäftigt haben und die kommen
alle zu dem schluss also zu 97 prozent
dass der klimawandel menschengemacht ist
wir brauchen sehr drastische maßnahme
weil es ein grad durchschnittlich wärmer
geworden ist und selbst das würde jetzt
für 100 oder 1000 jahre so bleiben
selbst wenn die menschheit morgen
aufhören würde benzin und kohle zu
verbrennen ja wieso zitiert den
weltklimarat richtig wenn wir nur dass
die temperatur von einem grad halten
wollten
dann bräuchten wir so drastische
maßnahmen
das wird es noch nicht mal schaffen
würden aber wir müssen alles dafür tun
damit wir eine erderwärmung von 1,5 grad
nicht überschreiten darauf pocht der
weltklimarat und das ist etwas wo wir
uns alle einig sein müssen das klingt so
pathetisch aber die mutter erde ist
tatsächlich unsere mutter unser eigenes
leben hängen brutal davon ab dass es ihr
gut geht stellt euch mal vor eure mutter
länger auf der intensivstation mit wem
was wir in der medizin denn multi organ
versagen das heißt nicht nur eine
krankheit sondern ganz ganz viele sachen
sind gleichzeitig krank das ist ein
medizinischer notfall das fieber steigt
steigt weiter
findet ihr es okay wenn dann sich
experten einmal im jahr treffen und
sagen oh ihrer mutter geht es aber
schlecht
wir treffen ist einem jahr wieder dann
gucken wir mal hoffen
nach besser geworden ist das ist total
inakzeptabel wenn es wirklich um unser
eigenes leben geht das sollte doch das
argument sein die klimakrise jetzt als
priorität auch in der politik zu
begreifen wenn die 15 grad erderwärmung
überschreiten gibt es ihre
der 17 die wissenschaft ist sich einig
dass wir 1,5 grad nicht überschreiten
dürfen wenn wir die nämlich
überschreiten dann ist es extrem
wahrscheinlich dass wir in so eine
unaufhaltsame spirale fallen wo es immer
wärmer wird egal was wir tun das ist
dann irreversibel nicht mehr rückgängig
zu machen in anderen worten dann haben
wir die erde kaputt gemacht na ja es ist
jetzt nicht so dass ist eine scharfe
grenze gibt und sagen wir drunter ist
alles cool und drüber ist alles kaputt
nein es ist eher so es wird immer
schlimmer
also die zwei grad erderwärmung die
irgendwann mal angedacht war
die ist deutlich schlimmer als die 15
grad die jetzt das neue ziel sein soll
und das ist auch noch immer schlimmer
als das was sie gerade haben nämlich ein
grad
es gibt ja jetzt schon ihre version also
unumkehrbare schäden es gibt ja jetzt
schon tierarten und pflanzenarten die
ausgestorben sind die nicht wiederkommen
ich möchte das abrufen aber anders
formulieren und zwar wir können uns
eigentlich nicht darauf verlassen dass
eine grenze wie zwei grad oder 1,5 grad
uns bewahrt vor dem großen übel ja dass
wir sagen
darunter ist noch alles cool sondern wir
sind jetzt jetzt schon im kritischen
bereich mit einer krassen umstellung ist
die schadensbegrenzung noch machbar
und hier kommen wir zur aussage 12 die
energiewende ist wirtschaftlich machbar
wissenschaftler an gezeigt dass wir viel
schneller auf erneuerbare energien
umsteigen könnten sogar weltweit die
berechnung unterscheiden sich in erster
linie darin dass die einen sagen ja das
wird genauso teuer wie die bisherigen
energieversorgung also win situation und
die anderen sagen es wird sogar
günstiger als die bisherigen
energieversorgung also win win situation
kostensituation gibt es ganz viele
studien die sagen also eine erneuerbare
energieversorgung zu 100 prozent ist von
dem kostenrahmen nicht teurer als die
konventionell die versorgung also es
gibt diese studien auf jeden fall aber
bei solchen berechnungen wäre ich immer
vorsichtig weil sehr stark davon abhängt
welche annahmen macht bei der berechnung
insofern aber was mich hier eigentlich
kirre macht ist dass wir kosten in
diesem fall nur finanziell betrachten
was absurd ist es ist ganz klar was für
einen hohen preis wir für den
klimawandel zahlen und noch zahlen
werden müssen der durch geld nicht
wieder wettzumachen ist
fällt uns menschen so schwer nach
unserer vernunft zu handeln weil wir
emotional wie ein kleinkind an dem
festhalten was wir im moment haben und
nicht sehen was wir in der zukunft
gewinnen oder verlieren können das ist
wirklich wie kleinkinder und
kurioserweise verhalten sich gerade
jugendliche wenn sie für freddie for
future auf die straße gehen viel
erwachsener als viele erwachsene in der
diskussion kleines beispiel durch den
heißen sommer 2018 haben wir auch
weniger getreide hierzulande geerntet
wird es teurer geworden prozent ungefähr
das sind für alle die brot kaufen jeden
tag in der summe schon mal eine
milliarde euro wir denken immer oh was
kostet die umstellung auf eine
nachhaltige energieerzeugung an
nachhaltige landwirtschaft das ist ein
klacks gegen das was es kostet wenn wir
jetzt nichts tun und es kostet uns heute
schon menschenleben und eine menge geld
wird rechnet nur keiner zusammen so
wieso kann ich nur sagen ich bin
beeindruckt von der intensiven recherche
die hier an den tag gelegt hat und vor
allem feiere ich natürlich dass er seine
quellen verlinkt ja ihr wisst ich mache
das auch immer also siehe video
beschreibung und eigentlich finde ich
alle müssten das tun ja ständig vor
politiker müssten für jede belastbare
aussage quellen verlegen das wäre mal
was gesamt sozialklima teil abruft was
ihr jetzt damit anfangen liegt in eurer
hand und macht wenn ihr diesen sonntag
wählen geht eins ist sicher wir brauchen
mehr junge stimmen bei dieser wahl denn
die jungen menschen sind es die noch
lange auf diesem planeten gut leben
möchten
und wenn euch klima wichtig ist dann
sollte euch auch diese europawahl
wichtig sein denn klima kennt halt keine
ländergrenzen publikum hand hoch wer von
euch packt regelmäßig in sein wohnzimmer
ich meine regelmäßig nicht aus effekt
oder so unser home is my castle unser
living room ist dort wo wir leben wollen
wir wollen da kein scheiß ich bin ja
gerne dafür der hoffnung zu verbreiten
es gibt drei konkrete dinge die jeder
von uns tun kann
erstens weniger fleisch essen zweitens
weniger fernzüge machen und drittens
politischer werden dann ist es quatsch
die veränderung nur auf der
individuellen ebene zu fordern
wir brauchen jetzt klare politik
rahmenbedingungen keiner von uns kann
dafür sorgen dass kerosin endlich
europaweit gesteuert wird es ist absurd
wenn wir in deutschland fliegen fliegen
als beantworten wir können immer noch
alle klimaziele erreichen wenn wir es
wollen wir haben die technik wir haben
das geld wir sind einander reichsten
länder der welt wer wenn nicht wir kann
jetzt damit anfangen es umzusetzen alles
was fehlt ist der politische wille dazu
kann ich nur noch sagen geht wählen wir
sehen uns nächste woche
bis dahin bleibt sicher